notre dernière journée à cannes je
reçois aujourd'hui à jacques brel
jacques brel acteurs mais aussi et
surtout metteur en scène puisque jacques
brel représente ici la belgique son film
représentait en belgique au festival de
cannes son film c'est le far-west
jacques brel j'ai retrouvé beaucoup
d'articles qui ont été criés écrit sur
vous celui ci par exemple vous disiez
vous même la chanson c'est un métier de
femelles ou d'enfants on se sent suivis
par une masse de gens qui ont le même
âge que vous et puis brusquement vous
avez 40 ans et plus personne n'est là il
vaut mieux abandonner les deux jours les
mêmes phrases on est toujours dans le
dédale esprit un peu prévu on peut prévu
qu effectivement que la france était un
métier de d'enfants de sommeil ça n'a
rien du tout péjoratif je ne crois pas
avoir d'effet majeur roger dû dire femme
normale chez les femelles
donc ce n'est pas un métier de marin
effectivement la chanson à côté est une
je crois une préoccupation de
d'enfants ou de le fumble de femmes
aujourd'hui je dirais femme n'est plus
en rimes et plus d'un million il si
aussi plein mais faut-il encore ne pas
se tromper sur sa passion oui faut être
honnête avec ses passions mes habiletés
dans certains cas comme cela c'est jean
vilain péché mortel qu'il faut fuir
toutes ses forces vous avez voulu fuir
j'ai voulu fuir la tentation de
l'habileté ça c'est très certainement
quand le quand le pouvoir remplace le la
douleur se relaient tout devient
déséquilibre n'est ce pas et on ouvre la
porte aux audi sport le plus complet il
faut pas faire ça à billou on est
enceinte ra
oui il faut être en difficulté je crois
tout se vit et quand les choses
fonctionnent bien c'est on va vers la
grisaille et mais c'était quand on
commence à se poser début des problèmes
qui sont des problèmes de luxe des
maladies luxe ça c'est aussi on parle
beaucoup des maladies de luxe vous êtes
de ceux qui pensent que la difficulté
c'est terriblement excitant
non je crois que ça fait partie de
l'accusé bon c'est pas tout le moins
excitant ça fait très peur mais je crois
que ça évite justement un certain nombre
de maladies de luxe où vivait avec les
gens auprès des gens
aux sauts je ne sais pas je vis avec les
jeunes
je crois que dans une certaine partie de
ma vie où je vis pour des gens jeu qui
me paraît plus intéressant mais c'est
peut-être la manière que vous avez de
vivre maintenant parce que lorsque vous
aviez 20 ans et comme nous le monde
sûrement vous deviez vivre pour vous
je crois que quand on est vilain tout
petit on se passe très vite de soi en
tant qu'être prioritaire
ça doit être très difficile d'être beau
à 15 ans
pour l'avenir
pourquoi vous dites parce que lyon parce
qu'on s'aperçoit très vite quand on
n'est pas bon ce n'est pas du tout un
complexe c'est un constat nous emparer
quand même souvent mais oui parce que je
crois que c'est une explication on
s'aperçoit très vite quand on n'est pas
au beau que l'intérêt qu'on peut avoir
n'est pas en soi mais dans le mouvement
que l'on peut éventuellement avoir ou
dans l'apport que l'on peut
éventuellement faire aujourd'hui alors
que les gens
bons souley le pôle d'intérêt ces cieux
et s'ils ne sont pas extrêmement
vigilant ils finissent par croire
mesdames existe on aime la beauté ce
n'est pas une éthique dans ce cas là et
shooting c'est la force d'exister oui
c'est l'année sable est venu se greffer
la question en ce qu'il voit sur des
mets vins en tournée c'est vrai et c'est
là que tout pilote au feu ou 15 ans 20
ans je crois vous êtes toujours vous
même dans tout ce que vous faites par
exemple dans france vous étiez déjà vous
m'avez je crois relativement fou oui oui
oui je crois en france bordeaux c'était
un monde dans lequel s'étaient laissés
enfermer des gens blessés mais des gens
blessés mais qu'il souffre pas c'est
cela c'est à peu près cela c'est cela
vous êtes blessé vous ne souffrez pas
oui c'est exactement ça je crois que le
il est extrêmement mal élevé lorsqu'on
est blessé de le faire savoir ça ne
concerne personne il est assez
détestable de rencontrer des gens qui
vous disent toujours que ça ne va pas je
crois c'est un problème de de bonne
éducation dans le vrai sens du goût de
dignité ce que vous êtes bien jacques
brats cause avait eu vous l'avez voulu
enfin dans leurs navires gloire non il
jouit en jour c'est un oui en gros c'est
ça c'est ça s'est beaucoup mieux passé
que mes rêves les plus optimistes les
sauces à sao les choses se sont passées
un peu à mon insu je n'espérais jamais
avoir une je trouve que j'ai une vie
formidable et je n'espérais pas du tout
du moins quand j'ai eu l'âge de raison
de tomber à 12 ans
je n'ai jamais espéré avoir une vie
comme celle que j'ai jamais je considère
ça comme un cadeau c'est fantastique et
encore maintenant je suis ébloui tous
les matins j'en parle parce que vous en
parlez vous parler de ce physique si
comme vous le dites
vous aviez thébaux vous auriez une
carrière tout à fait différent où je
crois que je n'aurais pas une carrière
du tout avait bien sûr bien sûr
ces villes
quand on est bon se suffit d'espoir
enfin ont suffi
maison de virgile suffisant en
vieillissement sans doute
je crois que c'est un grand danger
d'être beau au démarrage
[Musique]
ça facilite trop de choses oui ça donne
de fausses valeurs de soi
vous ne pouvez leur fils ou dans vos
chansons 4 vous même oh oui parce que je
n'ai je n'ai vraiment pas assez
d'imagination que pour être quelque
chose d'autre n'est ce pas et puis aussi
un problème de netteté
je crois qu'on a tous une énigme une
imagination limitée le tout cas moi j'ai
une image extrêmement limité et tout ce
que je peux faire c'est raconter ça à
temps à m'en servir je suis un tout
petit filtre si vous voulez
c'est tout c'est vraiment tout ou alors
il faudrait que je met à croire que j'ai
du talent les choses comme ça soit qui
sous des choses extrêmement dangereuse
vos films sont des indications vous
reparlera du far west tout à l'heure
mais en france il y avait quand même une
pénible approche des femmes par exemple
il ya d'une grande timidité oui sûrement
sûrement mais je crois aussi qu'il est
excellent d'être timide avec les femmes
c'est vous rapproche des hommes non ça
ne reproche pas obsédé je ne fais pas ça
exprès mais je crois qu'il est il me
paraît insensé de ne pas être timide
visé ville quoi que ce soit de vivant
je ne sais pas si je me fais bien
comprendre il s'agit de vivre sur la
pointe des pieds nous dérangeons à
chaque mouvement n'est ce pas alors il
faut une infinie pudeur pour se faire
pardonner le mouvement que l'on commet
je crois que je croise la vrai bon votre
vie a été une vie et toutes deux
mouvements oui
j'aime bien verser 2,2 beaucoup de
choses par exemple il ya chez vous une
une véritable absence de colère devant
les vacheries mais alors une colère
effroyable devant la justice
vous pouvez être terriblement
indifférent oui oui c'est une force
c'est une habitude à c'est la seule
habitée on devient on s'habitue à cela
n'est pas parce que il ya des colères
qui ne servent à rien
c'est sur
celle contre l'injustice peut-être
oui à tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est
pesé dans un sens ou dans un autre sens
on pèse par moment j'essaie de poser
mais tout cela est d y fait tout cela
d'arbitraire et je le sais mais il me
faut quand même posé j'aurais
l'impression d'être trop large si je ne
faisais pas de côté ou de l'autre et
gagner bordeaux jacques bral la justice
la plus flagrante du monde
c'est la naissance nous
ça n'est pas la naissance
je crois que l'injustice la plus
flagrante c'est le comportement
des adultes quand quelqu'un 10 ou 15 ans
parce que là il n'y peut rien il n'est
pas nécessairement avec ses parents cet
enfant moi j'étais avec mon mail à sa
joue
parce qu'en fait je crois que toute la
vie s'est décidée au moment où pour la
première fois
un être doué de raison se demande si ce
sont les adultes qui sont cons aussi
c'est lui qui se trompent
effectivement étant donné l'attitude des
rares adultes qui peut côtoyer à ce
moment-là de cette attitude là dépend la
réponse qui est définitive pour l'enfant
donc là il peut y avoir une justice et
si l'une des raisons qui vous poussent à
réinventer mais toujours le monde de
l'enfant
oui je crois comme kitsap je suis bon
jamais à l'enfance je crois que les
azzurri retenir des non ça n'existe pas
les adultes c'est une attitude on n'en
finit pas de courir après les rêves
qu'on avait quand on était petit c'est
sûr c'est pour ça qu'un homme qui
tremble pas devant une femme
il faut pas venir à dire que c'est de la
virilité
[Musique]
c'est de la sottise il faut tremblé
jusqu'à sa mort devant lui fait
sur vous il est toujours chez vous le
désir de convaincre vous ne pouvez pas
faire les choses gratuitement c'est pas
le désir de convaincre je voudrais
d'être convaincante en corne ou non je
voudrais c'est de faire comprendre que
je suis de bonne foi voilà on peut pas
demander plus mais vraiment je suis de
bonne foi je crois je suis bonne foi je
me trompe très souvent je sais cela mais
c'est de bonne foi
on a pu croire à un certain moment
lorsque vous avez dit j'abandonne la
chanson que ce serait seulement d'un
mouvement d'humeur mais vous avez
vraiment abandonne oui vu de nos
mouvements d'humeur dedans
mais vous ne revenez pas maintenant
parce que vous êtes orgueilleux et vous
dit non je ne peux pas revenir sur mes
décisions je suis certainement orgueil
de spa mais
mais ce n'est pas cela ce n'est pas cela
du tout oh non c'est parce que
je serais devenu adroit vous confondues
il ne faut pas devenir un droit acquis
peur de ne plus être tout à fait honnête
absolument
il y à mon avis trois quais catégorie de
chanteurs et bien ceux qui n'apportent
rien du tout il ya ceux qui apporte
seulement leur métier et puis il ya ceux
qui apportent leur propre univers et
dans cette dernière catégorie
y afférent ferré brassens il y avait
pire afilias training mais à d'autres de
jumeler brassens brassage pour vous
c'était les est-il disciples nom de
débuter en même temps
mais je crois qu'il n'y a pas plusieurs
catégories de chanteur je vous
attendez-vous vie ça ne pense pas ce
qu'on croit pas cela je crois qu'il ya
des gens
parfois on m'a demandé ce que je sais ce
que c'était qu'un artiste si vous voulez
enfin parce que c'est ça l'art je
connais pas je n'ai jamais pratiqué une
discipline stricte ne pas la chanson
c'est une petite route je crois aussi
que cinéma est une petite chose mais
je crois qu'un artiste c'est quelqu'un
qui a mal aux autres
et dans les chanteurs il ya les
chanteurs qui ont mal aux autres et des
chanteurs qui n'ont pas mal aux et puis
il ya aussi des gens qui ont du talent
les gens qui n'ont pas tout alors
j'essaie de savoir ce que c'était que le
talent et je crois que le talent c'est
d'avoir envie de faire quelque chose
mais ce n'est que cela et après il ya
toute une vie a usé pour essayer de
faire quelque chose
binya
c'était 12 des chanteurs c'est tous des
chanteurs et tous chanteurs correspond à
quelque chose et je crois que tous
firent nous correspond à quelque chose
et tout les frères correspond à quelque
chose et tous les primes correspondent
[Musique]
je crois qu'il faut oui je crois qu'il
faut auriez eu peur de ne pas être
sincère un jour elle ou même
seulement d'une raie beaucoup
cela dit comme j'aime à lourdes par de
conneries comme tout le monde il est
possible qu'un jour je crois je suis
sincère
parce que vous avez vous pourriez être
lâche comme tout le monde ça j'ai pas
envie
alors comment se préserver de la lâcheté
faut bouger faudra risques de la vie il
faut aller voir faut aller voir je crois
qu'il faut dé trouver deux curieux oui
il faut être scolaire
leaf que je crois qu'il faut être un
média où je sais pas je vais vous je ne
sais pas mais il ya deux manières de
réagir devant tout ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est décrété que cet idiot ou aller
voir
et je préfère aller voir et j'ai
vraiment un grand fait pour les hommes
qui vont voir
lorsque vous chantez à la jeunesse
l'amour ou chanter des choses perdues ou
des choses qui reviennent non des choses
qui me paraissent eux
insuffisamment points actuellement si
vous voulez qu'ils paraissent eux
on en manque voilà où nous en manque de
genève on en a marre or manque de
tendresse je crois c'est le maître mot
oui c'est un bon c'est un oui il ne faut
pas se coucher sur les mots non plus
mais on manque de tendresse ou et et on
manque dans de l'enfance enfants
manquent de 2,2 d'éblouissement
dans le temps ont montré les morts même
encore quand j'étais petit ouvrier les
morts dans les familles il y avait des
gens malades on les voyait mais on les
voit plus on l'envoyait les morts on ne
voit plus les morts et maintenant je
crois que les gens se croient bien
portant et de se croire bien portants se
croire et ernée
il n'ya qu'un pas et me semble-t-il par
moment un certain nombre de leurs
problèmes sont des problèmes d'immortels
alors qu'on est mortelle c'est en ça je
veux dire qu'il faut aller voir il faut
il faut savoir tous les jours qu'on est
mortel et l'idée de l'amendé pas une
idée triste c'est une idée une
solidarité fantastique
il ya plein de problèmes qui sont des
problèmes d'immortels et qu'ils ne
peuvent donc pas
un jour dans un article quelqu'un disait
jacques brel en fait c'est un un
disciple de péguy
c'est peut-être parce que d'avant-champ
sol et les refrains recoupent comme les
sillons de la beauce de pique je sais
pas ce que me faire beaucoup d'honneur
je ne sais pas si
je ne sais pas je crois que je continue
à aller à ses droits si vous voulez en
gros voilà mais c'est peut-être
uniquement par manque d'imagination vous
savez je n'en sais rien je vais à ses
droits face jeu je continue d'espèces de
chemins qui date de j'ai commencé quand
je vais à la fin de la guerre à la
libération
donc le problème de temps les sujets 45
ans jacques brel vous êtes belge il est
important d'être d'elle c'est important
c'est
ça pèse suffisamment certains moments de
la vie oui et puis ça c'est assez
rassurant d'autres moments sur le plan
du langage par exemple année ça n'est
pas facile
c'est un pays artificiel enfin ce dont
conviennent nulle part
et finalement c'est reposant de pouvoir
s'en référer et le belge ne peut pas
s'en référer
donc sonné
on est un peu cul-de-jatte
sur le plan de la mémoire
et seulement la chanson qui pouvait vous
conduire à quitter la belgique et
d'autres non je crois que je crois que
nous je crois que je serais porté
mais ce n'était pas pour quitter la
belgique c'était pour aller quelque part
et vous allez toujours quelque part oui
parce qu'on trouve jamais non non mais
on rencontre des choses sont vides à
ners ce film le far west qui avait
présenté demain à cannes c'était encore
la recherche de ce quelque part c'est ça
c'est son site ces deux hommes qui se
rencontrent alors qu'il recherchait qui
sort ce l'enfance
au vison en 15 ans tous les deux ou 50
ans et y joue aux revues de fin de de
buffalo bills colisée avant la guerre
parce que avant la gare je croyais que
le far-west c'était quand même le grand
paradis pour quand je serai grand enfin
quand mes jambes sûrs et plus au coi
j'irai vivre dans un far west quelque
part et puis je devrais pourquoi 45 ans
on n'a pas le droit de rêver oui vous
avez de la chance jacques brel parce que
vous réalisez tous vos rêves et en fait
quand vous avez les moyens de choisir
vos rêves
oubliés pas là ce n'est pas la chance de
tous et
c'est sûr que c'est de la chance
je sais pas si j'ai de la chance c'était
l'objectif du privé ce monsieur oui je
crois que le malheur c'est exactement la
différence qu'il ya entre le rêve et le
réel
donc il faut combler ce ces différentes
atteintes dans votre film le far west et
deux hommes qui partent à la recherche
de leur prison dit ne se parleraient ce
du far west et chasseurs l'arrouaise
mais disons qu'ils alors au bout mais
leur opl dessiner des biens services et
là c'est le sait le ces le alors les
alors enfin c'est ça
qui joua et juhasz quoi vous dites
souvent parce qu'on parlait justement de
la belgique je suis flamand ces flamands
par rapport à nos positions à wallon non
non je suis flamand enfin je suis de
caractère flamand je crois être plutôt
flamands que le rhénan ou du jour
valence les rhénans en fait c'est des
moments et les rhénans mais déjà là il y
à une opposition et ça nous donne
beaucoup chez vous parce que vous vous
installez une frontière alors que vous
avez toujours ailleurs l'injuste non
quand on me demande d'où je suis je dit
je suis flamand et de gravité je crois
être plutôt flamme enfin
je débloque un peu comme un flamand
comme l'assuré l'islam en vous pensez
que tout part du coeur et tout était les
rockers ces problèmes la générosité
je crois que c'est pas tout tout
problème et je crois que c'est ce n'est
qu'à partir de cette base là qu'on peut
devenir intelligent soit content d'être
intelligent coup dessus du coeur et
qu'on ne peut pas gommer le coeur pour
remplacer ça je crois ça parce que
l'intelligence et est une chose
extrêmement fugaces qui nous fait
prendre des décisions parfois très
importantes mais qui meurt dans la
seconde où elles ont été décidées
et c'est au coeur à maintes à faire le
boulot
je veux dire qu'on décide d'aimer
quelqu'un mais pour les mais c'est plus
la tête
c'est le coeur
en fait je crois que l'intelligence bien
plus souvent cercle des libye à notre
démarche qui tunis je crois que vous
avez 45 ans et pas dans la ligne
actuelle un sens j'ai dit non c'est dans
la culture oui faisait 45 ans et vous
allez sans cesse à la rencontre de
l'enfance c'est peut-être parce que vous
n'avez pas été un enfant susu je te
l'offre mais je n'arrive pas à savoir ce
que c'est qu'un adulte et je regarde
pourtant très attentivement et je trouve
ça assez gris si vous voulez avec tous
les signes extérieurs que cela comporte
et je préfère essayer de rester un
enfant ce n'est pas volontaire versées
parfaitement involontaire
si je n'arrive pas c'est dire que s'il
me fallait être adulte il me faudrait
jouer
voilà vous n'avez jamais joué même elle
nous mêmes on s'en doute que c'est
sans doute que si vous avez la ferveur
du moine mais vous ne pouvez pas être un
moine ça ne sais pas je
je ne sais pas ça oh il faut je crois
que pour être pour être moine il faut
avoir très peur aussi à les choses je
n'ai pas très peur à ces choses là
vous avez l'ardeur du guerrier mais vous
ne pouvez pas être un soldat
je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas si j'ai lors du guerrier
c'est j'ai envie que ce soit maintenant
oui combattants way combattants
l'inquiétude du poète et là vous êtes
prêts
vous auriez pu d'ailleurs être seulement
possède dans les prés toutes ses vitres
l'axé chemin tout est peut-être je ne
sais pas ça
je ne sais pas le fait d'avoir chanté
dans ce film oui
c'est plus un retour à la guitare qui
est votre vie qui votre évasion votre
système d'évasion votre objet d'évasion
plus en retours à la guitare qu'un
retour à la chance inouïe dont c'est pas
du tout retour à la chanson c'est parce
que les commis jouët au far-west ya des
cobras et les cowboys chante le soir
devant les feux de camp c'est tout ça
n'est que cela
je rappelle que nous sommes en ce moment
à cannes en direct du festival
dont l'invité jacques brel jacques brel
qui ce soir présente son film son
deuxième film le far west pour la presse
et demain devant comme on dit le tout
cinéma nous avons parlé de la chanson
nous avons parlé de bien d'autres choses
encore de la jeunesse de l'enfance
picasso jacques brel disait je ne
cherche pas je trouve
j'ai l'impression que vous vous trouvez
et vous cherchez après
je cherche je sais pas si je trouve jeu
sur wii cette démarche inverse même si
vous aviez trouvé vous diriez non
seulement passé je suis à 100 à lewis
est passé ça ne bouge plus il ya plus de
mourir
à cause de ça on peut penser que vous
reviendrez peut-être par d'autres jeunes
à la chanson allez musée je plantais par
ci par là oui à la vie musicale
oui peut-être joué la comédie musicale
ce n'est pas impossible cc c'est
toujours la chanson c'est une forme
louis ça n'est pas possible ça après
j'avais fait le dôme de la manche enfin
ça c'est pas impossible mais il est où
l'homme de la manche c'est cervantès il
peut y avoir je pars voyage au bout de
la lune c'est jules verne au
une nouvelle règle de pever des choses
oui c'est pas c'est impossible
d'y penser oui parfois oui parce que
c'est assez passionnant et pis c'est
dangereux oh que c'est dangereux la
comédie musicale en france autour c'est
très dangereux ailier la chanson il ya
le cinéma le théâtre payer la comédie
musicale oreille
et pas le roman non pourtant ces tenues
lors une église c'est tout notre argent
est certainement un autre à risques
c'est est une discipline majeure ça
c'est certain
mais
c'est pas souvent citée en existe ses
envies et puis c'est pas tous eu ça
donnerait j'ai l'impression d'être
encore trop passionné par ses
observateurs passé le voyeur
vous comprenez les trop jeunes en fait
oui mais un romancier justement ne doit
pas avoir de la retenue il doit le
laisser aller je crois qu'il doit voir
le manque de retenue je crois qu'il doit
en avoir
il doit voir le vendredi les autres de
ses personnages mais lydon avoir le
music hall ne donne pas beaucoup silva a
dit rêver un halo colette ou et colette
[Musique]
que ces mots oui c'est vrai oui on y
pense on n'y pense pas assez mes
collègues vient d'épingler
ces cinglés je crois qu'on peut dire
dire dans le cadre connaître que c'est
un écrivain qui est passé à voir une
lincoln fo com - c'est vrai faudrait
série on peut tricher un peu
je crois tout de même qu'au bout de la
route pour vous il y aura sans doute le
roman tout cas la chose littéraire c'est
possible c'est monsieur mais je crois
que les choses deviennent au fur et à
mesure comme ça il ne faut pas trop se
préoccuper de ces choses là je vienne et
à quel moment vous avez les compris vous
avez le sens de la poésie le sens du
texte
vous ayez fait de bonnes études logique
dans notre mauvaise études à guy
diplômes qu'on veuille ou non j'ai un
certificat d'études puis j'ai traîné
trois ans pendant la guerre où j'ai
doublé
je doublais touche était d'une très
haute médiocrité
on sape a poussé des coups alors c'est
justement ce nom et non une envie nos
vies
parce que là j'ai juste besoin enfin
j'essaie de chansons mais on pourrait on
pourra dire le texte de vos chansons
comme comme des pères au nom il ya des
chansons nous avait lieu il ya quelques
chansons qui devrait tolérer je veux
quelques dizaines de verres ont tous
mais sur 445 sens je crois qu'à
peut-être trois chansons ou de chansons
qu'on puisse lire par exemple pas fait
pour lorsque je retrouve celle ci enfin
juste à l'extrait où l'écouté et puis de
plus vous allez me dire si cet appel
avec des cathédrales pour unique
montagne et de noir clocher comme mât de
cocagne où des diables en pierre
décrochent les nuages avec le fil des
jours pour unique voyage des chemins de
pluie pour une expo soir avec le vent de
l'est écouter le vouloir le plat pays
qui est le mien c'est à poèmes plus
qu'une chance là oui c'est peut-être
plus un poème puissant sans bruit mais
vous le saviez pas en l'écrivant
vous avez quand on écrit on fait ce
qu'on peut
on le sait les choses qu après
on ne sait tous qu après on ne sait rien
pendant
ne sait rien est ce que vous êtes un
homme d'aujourd'hui jacques brel je sais
pas je sais pas
je crois je suis un homme d'aujourd'hui
de 45 ans
oui mais enfin oui je fasse je crois
être à peu près aujourd'hui fait c'est
quand même non parce que yahia c'est des
pros bonne dose de réussite si vous
voulez de de prudence d'intérêts qui lui
échappe complètement et il me semble que
ces problèmes-là cent des problèmes qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement prioritaire
et comme je ne les ai pas je me dis je
suis pas tout à fait un homme
d'aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas la
prudence c'est dur demain pour vous
n'est pas inquiétant nous
n'est pas d'intérêt non là et pourtant
vous avez gagné beaucoup d'argent oui
comment on peut lier les deux choses
il suffit pas d'aimer la fonction et peu
de résultats
mais le résultat on le tient toujours
revenons on le voit passer on s'organise
pour le voir passer dans jal est
sûrement là nous nous
nous
et je crois qu'il faut s'arranger pour
ne pas l'avoir
parce que c'est là qu'on s'installe vous
avez eu peur également être prisonnier
de l'ol ouais non gens me fait peur
oui me fait peur et c'est terrifiant
pour ne plus savez les gens riches le
mérite
quand je vois la vie que c'est ce
que ça leur impose oui ils le méritent
et vous êtes riche l'eau
avait peur d'être riche oui peut être
installée oui je n'aimerais pas ça du
tout parce que
le pouvoir rend idiots ils pouvaient
absolument absolument idiot comme disait
l'autre et puis l'argent sert une chose
les gens qui ont de l'argent ne pensent
qu'à l'argent qui leur manque
c'est très terrifiant et puis ça
l'argent fige les hommes l'héroïne
mobile pour un homme c'est fait pour
être mobile ça je suis sûr de ça je suis
incapable de vous le prouver mais je
suis sûr de cela un homme s'est fait
pour bouger c'est pas fait pour
s'arrêter c'est fait pour continuer pour
nous mais pour mourir en roulement
éventuellement mais ça ne tenait pas
fait tout le malheur vient de
l'immobilité toujours
les lisent les choses en étant team
mobile et d une phrase c'est parce que
le sujet d'une thèse les gens riches le
mérite et le mérite c'est un enfer l'
angoisse que ça que ça leur fils
tournant ce pas
en plus ça fausse fait rapport très
facilement oui mais à l inverse les gens
pauvres ne le mérite par je ne pense pas
j'en comment sortir quand je vous parle
d'aujourd'hui je vous parle de gens très
rifle
oui au-delà n'arrive tout est bien sûr
lorsque ça commence à devenir les ennuis
dès que c'est indécent
comment faut-il vivre debout de bruit en
mouvement
et ne jamais avoir le fatiguer parce que
là les murs vous tombe sur la tête
pour ça qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens
qui se courbe qui s'agenouille je ne
sais pas moi je ne suis pas là pour toi
pour dire que les gens se courbe où ça
je dois
je ne je ne sais pas si je cours je ne
crois pas qu'elle est tellement qui se
court mais qui s'agenouille il y en a
beaucoup qui s'arrêtent qui deviennent
immobile c'est sûr mais il faut dire
qu'il ya pas mal de choses qui qui les
arrête
jacques brel à 45 ans vous revenez sans
arrêt c'est bien parce que nous en
sommes toujours là vers l'enfance mais
imaginons que vous ayez 80 90 à 2 fois
s-class moment là il sera pas un peu
stupide de revenir du côté de l'enfance
ou alors est-ce que c'est une autre
enfant ce qu'il faudra rien d'euros 90
ans la nature s'est occupé de vous et
vous a ramené à l'état d'enfant mais ces
lettres mais c'est la fête
et j'en suis pas tellement et le corps
vous redevenez infirme comme un enfant
c'est un infirme un enfant ils marchent
pas
il faut pas vieillir
si lors si fauves et autres techniques
que sinon il faut dire il faut vire dans
la mobilité il faut vire on n'est pas
fait pour nous dans la lutte en effet
pour vieillir ce que de mourir c'est
s'arrêter le but de la vie servir d'être
immortel c'est non c'est d'être un
formidable de vieillard
c'est étonnant un formidable des gars
c'est mille fois plus fort que 20 ghz de
20 ans
n'avait jamais été à agacer attirés par
les religions parce que vous refusez de
vous les dogmes le dogme de la vie n'ont
jamais été je n'ai jamais de d'angoua sa
fin si c'est ce que vous voulez dire et
non la métaphysique également me paraît
un une espèce de chose qui me choque
c'est un code alors non
j'ai pas de il faut vous compreniez pour
tout ça je crois qu'il faut avoir
foncièrement très peur
et je crois qu'il faut croire qu'on est
capable de trouver une solution
or je n'ai je ne suis pas suffisamment
lâche que pour avoir cette peur là et je
suis pas suffisamment prétentieux
pourtant que je vais apporter une
solution à la peur que j'aurais
éventuellement
alors je ne suis pas croyant
et je suis pas philosophe plus dans une
chanson vous disiez c'est le tango
d'efforts en rien oui
belle définition et oui les gens qui
vivent
dans la vie ce qui compte c'est la vie
n'est ce pas ce n'est qu'à la vie
je sais rien d'autre je sais que dans la
vie ce qui est formidable c'est l'acte
de vivre et je ne sais vraiment rien
d'autre il acte d'aimer mais c'est dans
la vie cela n'est ce pas mais c'est la
vie ça ne va pas nécessairement aveugle
il là il faut commencer à s'en
préoccuper
tout le restant c'est du luxe ce père ce
sont des idées bizarroïde qu'on manipule
comme ça qu'ils reviennent depuis
[Musique]
depuis la renaissance italienne le
manceau revient comme ça c'est cyclique
quel est votre idéal
c'est essayer
français tentés s'est essayée tenter des
coups tenter des coups
et tenter des mails plus longtemps
possible parce que en fait le phénomène
de vieillissement la seule chose un peu
délicate c'est que au début au début si
on est un petit peu branché là dessus on
aime spontanément tout le monde et après
l'univers se restreint tout petit peu
pasqua et la difficulté consiste à
rester vigilants et se dire que quand on
n'aime pas quelqu'un
c'est quand même neuf fois sur dix parce
qu'on se trompe soit
c'est allé voir parce qu'on va moins
vite voire 45 ans qu'à 20 ans on dit
qu'on va voir on ne va pas toujours voir
il faut se battre il faut aller voir on
se regarde faut aller voir
jaguar tout à l'heure vous aviez dit
qu'il y avait chez une grande timidité
par rapport à la femme est en fait que
pensez vous de la fin n'a pas pas femmes
par rapport aux hommes est ce que je
pense de la femme je ne sais pas dès que
les hommes disent une chose au sujet des
femmes ils nous disent que des sottises
situent tous absolument incompréhensible
alors on décrypte dès midi et les hommes
pour par gravement mais ils disent que
des bêtises quand il perd les femmes
toujours et tous et tout le temps par
contre les femmes ne disent pas toujours
de ce titre intel pendu
mais c'est aussi sans doute parce que
les femmes se préoccupent des hommes
toute la journée et que l'homme ne s'en
préoccupe que dans la marche de ses
appétits vous pourriez rester avec une
femme toute une vie non mais
actuellement je crois que nous je suis
même sûr que nous actuellement parce
qu'il n'est pas possible de faire un
contrat pour une vie non parce que ce
seul but vide n'est ce pas
ça s'abîme trop vite il faut faire durer
les choses belles
vous avez des enfants réserve et j3 aux
trois filles dont quel âge qui ont 20
ans 21 ans 20 ans et 15 ans et c'est
difficile de vivre avec elle pour lui
tout d'abord il faut que je sois pas
aller je ne vis pas avec elle pas pas
quotidiennement
mais elles me sont étrangères non pas
parce que ce sont mes filles mais parce
que ce sont des femmes
je vais pas faire semblant d'être le
gars qui comprend je ne comprends pas
il faut être honnête et je crois que
c'est beaucoup mais c'est à dire je vous
comprends pas
mais elle elle vous comprennent ont
sûrement pas et là c'est pas parce que
je suis un homme c'est parce que là il
ya une génération
c'est très difficile il faut du foot de
bonne foi fut étouffée tron est tous les
reports trois filles et il aurait fallu
un garçon
tout un truc ça je ne sais pas où il va
occuper de votre descendance nous
nous non
je ne sais pas s'il vous est souhaitable
parce que je ne sais pas et puis c'est
ainsi fais pas vous n'allez pas
m'obliger à tout remettre en question
jacques brel vous dites et je vous crois
la chanson plus jamais mais je vous
rappelle qu'en 65 lorsque vous avez posé
cette question le cinéma vous aviez
répondu jamais oui je veux en 65 je
sentais qu'on me dise que voulait faire
du cinéma je dis non je crois pas mais
j'ai encore une fois vous hissez prouve
bien qu'on dit des sottises sujet de ce
qu'on ne sait pas d'où part de chansons
je sais à peu près je crois que surtout
vous ne voyez pas mélanger les jours
vous fier à ce moment là il faut faire
des choses assez sérieusement n'est ce
pas et c'est vrai que je n'y croyais pas
je croyais plutôt que je vais faire
beaucoup de comédies musicales à
l'époque secret et cela et puis le sait
c'est venu comme ça enfin
je me suis plus au jeu ça m'excite c'est
formidable enfin je crois qu'il faut
essayer de rester disponible aux choses
bon vous avez réalisé ce deuxième film
le far west est ce que vous êtes content
de vous vous ne serez jamais des
contrôles non c'est pas possible ce
couteau je fais tout ce que je peux je
fais tout ce que je peux pour encore
pour raconter des rêves qui je crois
correspondent à une préoccupation d'un
certain nombre de gens
vraiment je le crois je crois qu'il ya
plein d'hommes de mon âge
d'où de mon temps
et qui ont un manque d'enfant ce qui est
vrai
qu'ils compensent en général par la
réussite ou par les femmes
je crois qu'ils ont ils ne jouent plus
au cow boys et aux indiens et ça manque
alors j'essaie de raconter ça peut-être
naïvement mais très honnêtement j'essaie
de le faire seulement de là vous dire
que je suis content si je vous disais
non
ce serait
je serais malhonnête en vous disant hé
hé oui et non formé en fait jacques brel
aujourd'hui être naïf est ce que ça
n'est pas la seule manière d'être à lui
c'est la dernière façon d'avoir une
santé morale une dernière phase en avait
près de santé morale ça ne veut pas du
tout dire être prises mais c'est faire
naïvement les choses c'est faire les
choses avec son coeur
el far west là c'est la liberté cette
liberté est ce que vous l'avez trouvée
est ce que vous l'avez retrouvé ce que
la 20 10 oui oui je le veux je crois
l'avoir enfin avec toutes les
restrictions pour sans fin jade est sans
doute beaucoup plus que la plupart des
gens oui je crois mais pour vous venir à
cannes c'est faire une concession non
pas du toit vous êtes l'afsset
réalisateur et metteur en scène vous
êtes peut être au bout de ce que vous
vouliez faire la belle c'est la fin du
film et comme ce film a été sélectionné
les distributeurs m'ont demandé de venir
or ce sont des gens qui m'ont fait
confiance c'est un petit film soul est
un film à petit budget mais ces gens
m'ont fait confiance
il me semble normal que par bonne
éducation si vous voulez pas vraiment eu
l'occasion ces gens vont avancer de
l'argent pour hier les un rêve que je
viens à cannes pour pour pour le rêve et
pour être gentil puisqu'il me demande
dans quel état je crois qu'on ne leur ai
pas demandé je ne serais pas venu je
vois le fond de la pensée mais on me l'a
demandé et on me l'a demandé gentiment
je suis venu voilà dans quel état serez
vous lorsque ce film sera présenté je
serai terrorisé n'est ce pas ça c'est
évident je serai absolument quand la
projection va commencer je vais être
complètement terrorisée
d'abord parce que je connais le film
puisque et en plus je joue dedans ok il
ya deux choses c'est terrorisant ce
n'est ce pas ça c'est faire un grand
malade et mais se voir mais c'est le
verdict qui vous fait peur à nana de nom
c'est celle heure et demie de projection
pour moi de cette scène vous la
connaissez bien vous avez changerait la
causerie oui je connais bien la salle en
salle ce que la salle mais vu de l'autre
côté droit
mais pas le même univers ça n'a rien à
voir et si le far west avec un prix
c'est une éventualité pour vous
donc ça me prouve que vous êtes
également rêveur un coup
moi je rêve non mais celle-là n'est pas
là n'est pas le problème
c'est que
c'est pas ça le problème
où est le problème alors c'est de faire
convenablement ce qu'on veut faire il
est là l'important c'est de faire les
choses c'est d'aller voir c'est de le
faire c'est ne pas dire tiens et bien
l'année prochaine si j'ai un peu de
temps je vais faire et moi j'aimerais
bien faire et il ya trois ans que je
pense un bouquin et je vais peut-être
non l'important c'est de fait ces deux
là les voir l'important c'est de se
mettre au pied du mur et alors si on a
mal calculé son élan si on se heurte au
mur et qu'on se casse la tête il faut
pas insulter les gens c'est qu'on s'est
cassé on se trompe soit il n'ya que
finalement les gens totalement immobile
et qui ne font jamais rien qui arrivent
à traverser la vie en disant que tous
les autres sont cons ou ou à peu près
dès qu'on fait les choses on devient
d'une humilité fantastique dès qu'on va
voir on a vraiment peur ils sont sur les
terrains d'aviation j'ai piloté
longtemps ce qu'on appelle en vfr sur le
vol à vue
il ya deux sortes de gus en bas et le
bus car il est à côté de son avion est
dit avec ce temps là il faut pas y aller
et lui il a toujours raison bien sûr il
a toujours rêvé
et à les autres disent qu'ils disent il
faut aller voir alors on décolle on a un
peu peur on a même vu un peu on va voir
en revue ont fait demi tour on passe ne
passe pas ça là bas on est allé voir si
c'est un échec on l'a mérité c'est ou
parce qu'on a eu peur en route ou parce
qu'on n'est pas assez bon pilote ou mais
c'est soi et les autres effectivement ne
se trompe jamais mais ils finissent par
ne plus avoir de vie sans se faire
absorber par une femme et part de m
avoir deux enfants un enfant plus à
croire à l'immortalité de l'âme et je ne
veux pas faire ça je peux faire
continuer à être en marche jacques brel
aussi les bars ou les moins solitaire
que music hall mais demain soir dans
cette salle que vous connaissiez bien il
y aura tout le public et j'ai
l'impression vous serez très seul parce
que vous serez avec vous même non moi je
serai seul parce que je sais ce qui va
passer
parce que et si le public ne réagit pas
au bon moment c'est bon vous savez où
vous savez ça st c'est très possible de
passer très très possible c'est très
possible mais encore une fois si ça si
ça prend un bon beat des temps c'est
bien fait pour ma gueule il faudra
surtout pas je dise que c'est des
cornichons après ça serait malhonnête
ouvriers ça serait malhonnête c'est
quand on fait quelque chose quoi qu'il
arrive avec cette chauffe c'est bien
fait pour sa gueule on fait quelque
chose mais je préfère de loin le
pulvériser la gueule que reste immobile
et dire que je vais faire quelque chose
trou puisque les autres font ils
intéressent je préfére allez voir vous
êtes plein d'appréhension avant cette
rencontre avec les journalistes
donc avec les journalises ya un moment
que vous ne verrez pas rencontré bah oui
et oui non ça non ce nous ça nous je
parlais de solitude c'est
solitaire ou secrets plus secret que
solitaire
peut-être oui peut-être ou et pas très
solitaire tout
secret vue mais vous savez quand on fait
beaucoup de choses on al'air secret non
en fait c'est uniquement parce qu on est
tout le temps en mouvement
ça revient sans arrêt sans arrêt le
mouvement lancé le mouvement le
mouvement
dès qu'on est immobile on se rencontre
et on se donne priorité bien se dissout
dans des phrases que les autres j'ose
plus prononcée aujourd'hui vous dites
par exemple moi je lave ou je suis un
homme heureux oui oui enfin je croise
mes filles venant quand je dis heureux
un jeune aux jeunes je ne dis pas cela
ce temps là je crois qu'en gros je suis
plutôt un homme heureux oui oui
oui parce que vous l'avez voulu aussi
parce que je les ai voulu et puis parce
qu'on fait je crois que le temps des
choses que de moi
parce que vous ne faites pas confiance
aux autres non mais parce que je trouve
sur coville à l'église ya peu d'égoïsme
non je trouve ça mal gré de temps que
les gens vous donnent des choses ou que
la vie vous donne des choses il faut
s'en occuper
quand on va quand on a mal aux dents à
20 ans et qu'on sait pas procéder dans
convenablement avant tout les jours ça
va il est vrai que toutes nos actions ne
peuvent pas être ou ne peuvent pas avoir
des chances d'aboutissement raison de
vous avez compris vous c'est que toute
la vie c'était simplement une somme de
petits cris oui c'est ça le petit
tentative qui s'accumulent il se
retranche gina qui savent créer des
canaux qui se créent
une notice of kri rihanna qui crie
alors découvrir ses vives rose et
découvert beaucoup de choses alors
quelle sera la prochaine découvert je
sais pas parce que le roman vous m'avez
dit peut-être et comédie musicale vous
n'avez 10 heures de route oui j'ai
souvent vous n'avez lis je sais pas il
faut laisser venir les il faut laisser
venir les choses
aient vraiment vous pensez que vous
aviez continuer dans la chanson vous
auriez été malhonnête je ne le pense pas
je pense ouais je me pensais pour
plusieurs raisons
d'une part à l'écriture vous savez c'est
très fatigant d'écrire c'est très
difficile d'écrire et au fini par avoir
un certain nombre de trucs qui
compensent ces trucs ce fait notre trou
sans doute devenu de plus en plus
fréquents et ensuite il ya l'animal qui
chante sur scène qui est un être
complètement différent de l'animal sur
scène ne peut pas impunément jouer aux
gamins parce que son corps n'est plus
encore de gamin
donc il y avait une main d'honnêteté
je crois au cinéma vous ne pouvez pas
être malhonnête ce n'est pas du tout
sion peut l'être bien sûr au cinéma je
dois dire que je sais tellement peu de
choses du cinéma que le problème de
l'habileté ne s'est encore jamais imposé
à moi quant au problème du corps au
cinéma ça dépend du rôle qu'on
interprète
je veux dire quand on écrit le film
vous avez toujours dit jacques brel
jeures j'ai un terrible besoin de
liberté j'ai un terrible besoin de vivre
la liberté vous avez des claviers mais
est ce que vous vivez vraiment qu'on
fait je veux que je vis fort
jugeait très fort vivre pas osé faire ce
que vous avez profite fait feu
sans concession
sans doute s'en sont trop de concessions
sans concession si c'est possible en
gros ce sera en passant de la chance au
cinéma voulait changer d'air alors le
stérilet mot moins polluer cela même
alors il et je n'ai jamais trouvé très
pollué - steria
l'un de leurs le cinéma moi je pose la
question
le cinéma l'ennui c'est que cette chose
qui coûte cher en tant que styliste à
stylo très onéreux
mais le c'est la même chose au fait il
ya des gens moi j'ai rencontré dans le
cinéma des gens que je trouve très
remarquable
vraiment très bien
très très bien vraiment des gens du 2t
qui ont par exemple dont deux le temps
de l'enfance aux fins d'une façon
extraordinaire
faut avoir beaucoup d'humilité pour
faire du cinéma car en fait tout est une
question de hasard je crois qu'il faut
enfin en fait foi qu'il faut de
l'humilité pour rien je parle de soigner
ma vaste zone à cannes mais je crois
qu'il faut l'humilité pour rien je crois
que quand on fait quelque chose on
devient une humble
créateurs et tout ce n'est pas tout à
fait c'est papon sable sans quoi c'est
pas pour sable puisque justement on s'y
fait quelque chose c'est parce que il
essaie de combler tout ce qui manque
mais c'est une chance pour le créateur
parce que je fais une création il n'y a
pas de création il constate encore
pauvre mais constatant son sac il est
tellement insuffisant qui devient humble
je crois vous ne regrettez absolument
rien de ce qui a été si vous regrettiez
d'ailleurs nous serions idiots je
regrette que la guerre ait duré quatre
ans
ce n'était pas voulu c'était pareil mais
ça je le regrette des choses analyse je
regrette cet élan mais je crois que
c'est la seule chose que je regrette de
ma vie
pour regretter de ne pas avoir participé
non ou il faut juste pas le problème ne
se pose pas je veux je vais à 11 ans je
vais dix ans il se pose puisque vous ne
trouvez serait allé cet élan c'est
dommage que c'est tout sinon c'est
dommage
c'est dommage
dans votre vie je n'ai brasure jacques
brel que
tout est libre et tout est prévu oui
c'est une fabuleuse organisation oui
mais kick in si vous voulez je pose un
certain nombre de décisions qui sont
parfaitement arbitraire et je m'arrange
après pour pour aller au bout de ses
décisions de façon organisée voilà je me
trompe et puis je m'arrange pour que
cette erreur soit la moins lourde
possible
mais vous êtes capable encore de faire
des erreurs un peu tout le temps vous
vous donnez la chance de faire des jeux
veut je vais voir se veut voir je veux
pas trop prudent je vais voir
bon maintenant il ya ce deuxième film le
far west la troisième tentative ce sera
un film en plus je ne sais pas si j'en
suis vraiment rien tiens c'est vraiment
rien vous vous êtes un réalisateur vous
vous mettez en scène aux électeurs nous
être pas un peu trop
peut-être je t'ajoute fait c'est
toujours brel mais oui c'est ça que oui
j'ai rêvé du mans 1-1 un manque total de
mesure c'est certain
d'un autre côté dans dans le cinéma
c'est bien commode de pouvoir aller
jusqu'à faire soi même la musique n'est
ce pas et puis il faut pas story et des
problèmes économiques il faut que ça me
permet de faire puisque je fais ça pour
l'expérience ça me permet de faire des
tas de choses comme ça que je pourrai
pas voter ailleurs
comprenez que je fais ça
ça m'oblige à tout faire enfin faire
beaucoup
ses pensées de tous ces chanteurs qui
passe passe au cinéma
abc mad veut non non je ne sais pas je
ne sais vraiment pas ça y'en a pas eu
tellement
il ya eu mon temps où il ya bien des
coups
bas qui ont pris véritablement le risque
qu'il y à vous aimons tant
oui oui je crois vous avez parlé avec
mon temps de devaux carrière nous jamais
jamais non je connais mon temps il a
chanté une chanson en moins de temps je
ne connais pas intimement enfin je ne
connais pas trop vous connaissez les
autres nous je connais un peu brassens
enfin je connais précise parce que vous
n'avez pas envie de les connaître
vous savez dans music hall on est tous
tout seul enfin
les tournées sont séparés
au
théâtre les gens travaillent ensemble au
cinéma aussi mais par auxerre c'est une
ville d'isoler le vide music hall c'est
pas que je peux en vie
lorsque vous regardez sur l'écran
moi j'aime pas
c'est toujours votre vieux fantasme je
ne suis pas beau
non c'est pas du tout parce que je suis
pas beau non ça c'est parce que je suis
pas bon souvent c'est surtout ça n'ont
cessé ces deux c'est plutôt ce côté là
non je je
je ne crois pas que quelqu'un puisse
aimer se regarder vraiment pas
là je me rappelle la télévision je
passais une chanson de vous étiez près
de moi et après la chanson c'était les
flamandes m'avait dit cette petite
phrase quelle santé j'avais oui c'était
au passé oui ou non mais je crois que je
vais encore dur mais c'est ça je me dis
je me suis dit là que je suis c'était
vraiment un phénomène de santé oui j'ai
encore s'être senti la lire
l'avenir pour vous n'allez pas une
inquiétude mais pour vous tout seul
non ce point d'inquiétude c'est je crois
qu enfin j'aimerais bien pouvoir encore
faire rêver quantité de sources côtoyer
des quantités de gens allaient et est
allé voir où je vais craquer ça c'est
formidable
mais pas faire un autre métier qu'elle
me disait ce que j'ai là c'est plus
vieux métier je fais moi j'essaie de
vivre ça ne soit que c'est pour une
question de métier vivant c'est de vivre
et c'est facile non ce n'est pas facile
mais c'est passionnant c'est tellement
passionnant que c'est formidable
c'est formidable
à les voir tous
voir où on va craquer
parce qu'un jour je vais craquer tout le
monde craque et si demain vous craquiez
moi je crois que jean contre santé je
refais roadshow
justement après la projection du film
parce que peut-être le public n'aime pas
se tromper c'est un homme c'est pas ça
que je veux dire craquer non ce que l'on
croit ce sera une forte envie de demain
quoi oh oui boerenbond vide vous pouvez
prendre un beat vos bras autour du prix
des paquets ah oui et oui oui je connais
bien non ça oui je prendrai le le la
bonne claque dans la gueule que mais
avec avec bonne santé voyons de toute
façon est en fait la chose je suis
prioritaire par rapport aux gens qui ne
font pas
vous comprenez vous avez déjà pris les
devants parce que vous avez dit pour
faire un bon finish foire d'abord offert
15 salle et au deuxième oui aux jupes à
10 15
c'est ce que je crois que je ne vois
jamais dire il faut peut-être au moins
en faire qu'un jeu
au moins
qui veut dire je prépare mes coups je
sais pas oui je sais pas je
sais pas c'est pas organisés sur ce plan
là tout ça tout ça est une aventure
c'est pas vivre c'est formidable mais ça
n'est pas sérieux ça n'est pas grave il
faut fuir la gravité des imbéciles qu'il
faut fuir sein de toutes ses forces
c'est une aventure c'est presque un jeu
je suis un seul mot
[Musique]